bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte le
printemps dernier on a eu l'impression
que le monde s'était arrêtée mais deux
secteurs n'était pas en pause celui de
la santé et celui de l'agroalimentaire
alors que les frontières étaient fermées
et que la pénurie de main d'oeuvre se
faisait plus criante que jamais les
agriculteurs les transformateurs et les
distributeurs devraient continuer de
nourrir la population
[Musique]
31 décembre 2019 la chine informe
l'organisation mondiale de la santé de
la présence d'un virus jusqu'ici inconnu
sur son territoire
un mois plus tard le même virus est déjà
présent sur 4 continents
[Musique]
le 11 mars 2020 le ms déclare l'état de
pandémie
partout sur la planète des efforts sont
déployés pour contrer la propagation du
virus
[Musique]
nous fermerons nos frontières aux gens
qui ne sont pas citoyens ou résidents
permanents du canada au canada les
mesures sont chaîne fermeture de la
frontière des commerces des entreprises
g20 conseil des ministres auquel
gouvernement adopte un décret pour
déclarer l'état d'urgence sanitaire sur
tout le territoire québécois
fermeture des écoles des bars et des
restaurants l'interdiction de
rassemblement
la population est confiné à demeure
l'économie paralysée jugé essentiel la
production agroalimentaire est épargné
elle demeure en opération
mais rapidement la pandémie a
déstabilisé de manière fulgurante et les
filières production approvisionnements
et distribution des aliments
ça a été vraiment satisfaite un choc moi
je m'attendais pas à ce choc là
personnellement au canada un peu plus de
60% des aliments produits vont à la
grande distribution c'est à dire aux
épiceries et aux distributeurs
près de 40 % alimente les restaurants
les cafétérias les hôtels les
institutions or ces établissements sont
fermés
il ne se vend plus de nourriture pour
les banques et d'hôtels les restaurants
les cafétérias les garderies ou les
repas d'avion parallèlement on assiste à
des achats de masse les consommateurs
font des réserves
s'ensuit une rareté des aliments et
rapidement des surplus parce que ce qui
s'achète à l'épicerie c'est pas les
mêmes formats sepa lehmann emballages
que ce qu'ils vivent dans la
restauration et l'hôtellerie
le distributeur alimentaire était pas
prêt à cette demande dans des épiceries
les fournisseurs non plus
leurs sacs se répercute dans toute la
filière agricole
aucune ferme n'y échappe une crise
inhabituel c'est celle qui a touché de
façon transversale tous les secteurs
d'olic de l'agriculture les potes de
secteurs qui ont été épargnées vraiment
les producteurs agricoles en paie le
prix toute la production la distribution
doivent être repensées plus rien de
sièges
par exemple l'ouverture de la pêche
sportive est incertaine nos 160 tonnes
de truites d'ensemencement risque de
suffoquer en bassins d'élevage les
fromages fins destiné au restaurant la
viande spécialisés comme le cerf tous
les grands gibiers ne se vendent plus
en revanche rarement consommer du bison
à la maison on va au restaurant on va le
faire
alors eux aussi ont perdu pratiquement
100% de leurs marchés subitement
la frontière fermée l'arrivée de la main
d'oeuvre étrangère indispensable aux
cultures est incertaine
les producteurs maraîchers qui
embauchent 85 % des ouvriers étrangers
manque de main d'oeuvre
ils perdent leurs récoltes primeur
pendant que d'autres diminue les
surfaces en cultures
la sécurité alimentaire est en jeu avec
le manque de main d'oeuvre aux
etats-unis aussi dans certains secteurs
en europe
ça a affecté toutes les productions à
travers le monde
moi j'étais inquiet sur les prix des
aliments après quelques mois ça peut
demeurer encore inquiète au plus fort de
la pandémie à la mi avril
la maladie frappe les employés
d'abattoirs et deux usines de
transformation
le plus gros foyers d'éclosion a su
revenir au pays éclate dans un abattoir
de boeuf 2k games en alberta près de
1000 employés sont infectées au québec
ce sont des employés d'une usine
d'abattage de porcs qui sont frappés par
la maladie comme les animaux attendent
dans les parcs d'engraissement et
porcherie les revenus des éleveurs chute
le prix de la viande en épicerie monte
en flèche
[Musique]